Welcome back.
We're now on problem
number 11.
Let's see, at the top they
write z, w, y, x.
And they say, the sequence above
may be changed in either
of two ways: either two adjacent
letters may be
interchanged, or the entire
sequence may be reversed.
So either I could switch
w and y, or I could
just switch the order.
What is the least number of
changes needed to put the
numbers into alphabetical order
from left to right?
So, what is alphabetical order
Let's do our goal, because it's
been a while since I've
sung my alphabet.
So it's w, x, y, z, this
is our goal, right?
So let's see what we can do.
w x, y, z,
So we need to get w at the
opposite end from-- So let's
see, if I could switch these
two, then I would
get z, w, x, y.
No, no, no, no, no, I want to
get the w at the opposite end.
So what we want to do is
switch w and y, right?
And we would get z, y, w, x.
Then you could switch x and w.
You would get z, y, x, w.
And then the other option we
can do is just reverse, and
then we can reverse.
And when we reverse it,
we get w, x, y, z.
And that's our goal.
So that took us one step,
two steps, three steps.
So that's choice B.
I'm not sure if that's
the right answer.
Let's see if I can do
it in two steps.
Let's see, if I reversed
it-- well reversing
doesn't really help you.
The bottom line is you have to,
before you reverse w, x,
y, z-- I mean, to move the z all
the way over to the other
end, no, you want
to just reverse.
If you reverse this, and you
reverse this, and you switch,
I think that's the fastest
possible way.
No matter what you do, you have
to move the w two steps
away from the z.
You have to do that, right?
Because the w is on the opposite
end from the z, so
you have to move the w twice.
That's going to take you
at least two steps.
And then you've got to
switch the order.
That's the third step.
And it would be even worse if
you didn't switch the order
and wanted to move the z.
The other option is you could
just flip the z and the w, and
you would get w, z, y, x.
And then you could switch-- no,
that's going to take you--
you could switch the x and the
y and you'd get w, z, x, y.
Now that's going to take you
three or four steps, so I'm
pretty sure we got
the right answer.
Write me a little note
if I didn't.
Next problem.
The bottom line with that one,
you have to realize you have
to move the w at least three
away from the z, and then
you've got to reverse it.
So it's going to take you
at least three steps.
Problem number 12.
I hope I'm right on that one.
How many cubicle blocks, each
with edges of length 4
centimeters, are needed to fill
a rectangular box that
has inside dimensions-- So each
of my initial blocks--
I'll draw my cube as best as
I can-- are 4 by 4 by 4.
And that is how many
cubic centimeters?
These are centimeters, right?
So 16 times 4 equals 64
centimeters cubed, or 64 cubic
centimeters.
And we want to fill a box that
has inside dimensions-- this
is my big box, let's see--
20 by 24 by 32.
So there's a couple of ways
you could do this.
You don't even have to do
this first step I did.
You could just say well, how
many of these small boxes are
going to fit in this
direction?
How many are in this direction,
and how many in
this direction, and
then multiply.
And that's actually the
fast way to do it.
So instead of drawing it that
way you could-- let me redraw
that big box-- but instead of
giving it in centimeters, let
me give it in how many of these
boxes are going to go in
this direction.
So it's going to be, these are
4 centimeters each and the
base is 20, so it's going
to be 20 divided by 4.
It's going to be 5 in
this direction.
It's going to be 6 in this
direction, 24 divided by 4.
It's going to be 8 in
this direction.
So then you can just multiply,
5 times 6 is 30, times 8 is
240 of the boxes.
The other way to do it is you
could have multiplied 20 times
24 times 32.
You could have said this equals
20 times 24 times 32,
and then divided by 64.
That would have been the other
way of doing it, and then it
would have just required
more math.
And hopefully that comes out to
the same thing as 240, and
that's choice D.
If you ever find yourself on the
SAT doing something that's
really hairy or taking a
lot of time, you're not
necessarily doing it wrong, but
there's probably a faster
way to do it.
Because they want you to be able
to do these questions in
less than 30 seconds.
I think you have time
to do them in a
little over a minute.
Thirteen, if 0 is less than n
which is less than 1, which of
the following gives the correct
ordering of square
root of n, n, and n squared?
Do you know what the easiest
thing to do when they give you
a problem like this is?
Just try out a number.
Well do you know what a good
number is here, because we're
going to have to take the
square root of it?
Let's take n equals 1/4, because
it's easy to take the
square root of 1/4.
So if n is equal to 1/4, then
what are these values?
Square root of n is equal
to 1/2, right?
It actually equals plus or minus
1/2, but they probably
mean the positive 1/2.
n is 1/4, right?
And what's n squared?
n squared is 1/16.
I'm assuming that they mean the
positive square root when
they write it like that.
So what's the order of these?
They want to do it from the
smallest to the biggest, so
the smallest is n squared.
Then the next biggest
is square root of n.
No sorry, then the
next one is n.
And then the next one
is square root of n.
And that is choice E.
And another way to think about
it is, when you have a
fraction-- and essentially
that's what they're saying,
that you have a fraction less
than one, or you have a
decimal point-- it becomes
bigger when you take the
square root, and it becomes
smaller when you square it.
That's the realization.
So the squaring is going to be
smaller than the number which
is smaller than the
square root.
That's the underlying theme
when a number is
between 0 and 1.
But if you didn't want to think
too abstractly about it,
just try out a number
that works.
Let's see, next problem,
problem number 14.
OK, so this is going to
involve some drawing.
Let me see if I can draw
this pretty fast.
So that's my y-axis.
That's my x-axis.
Then there's a bunch of lines.
There's a, b, c.
OK, so they all intersect
at 3.
And then these are 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, and 6.
And let me draw out
all the lines.
So the first line goes
something like
this, it goes there.
Then all the other ones--
and let's see, the
next one goes to 3.
The next one goes to 4.
The next one goes to 5.
They all go to y equals 3.
And the last one goes to 6.
OK.
And they're saying in the figure
above, what is the
median of the slopes
of all of those
lines, oa, ob, oc, right?
They write A, B, C, D, E.
What is the median?
So this isn't the average.
Median is easier.
Median is just what's the
middle slope, right?
So we could say well this-- let
me just switch colors--
line A has the highest slope.
Line B is a little bit lower.
Line C is a little bit lower.
The slope is getting a little
bit lower as we go out, right?
And you could figure that
out by rise over run.
The rise is the same in every
case, and the run just gets
bigger and bigger, right?
The change in x gets
bigger and bigger.
So this has the highest slope.
This has the lowest slope.
And this has the middle
slope, C.
Pretty easy.
Oh, the median of the slope.
So they want you to
figure it out.
So what is the slope
of 3, of this one?
So it's change in y is 3 over
change in x, which is 4.
So it's 3/4, so that's
choice C.
If you got this wrong, maybe by
accident you took the mean,
or the average, which would
probably have wasted a lot of
time as well.
I'll see you in the
next video.